der fatale herr ost konflikt im
klassenzimmer eran riklis film hat
premiere auf der piazza grande in der
heimat des israelischen regisseurs
herrscht krieg sein neuer film dancing
drops beschäftigt sich mit dem
schwierigen zusammenleben von israelis
und palästinensern
er tut dies mit erstaunlicher
leichtigkeit dieser konflikt ist ein
schwieriges thema auch hier in lugano
wenn die geschichte aber mit
jugendlichen protagonisten erzählt wird
dann wird dieser konflikt plötzlich zu
einer geschichte über dich und mich
sie und ihn der große konflikt gebündelt
in der figur des jungen er wird in ein
elite internat aufgenommen
als einziger palästinenser kämpft gegen
sprachbarrieren und rassismus vor allem
aber hat verliebt sich in die juden
der schauspieler torfweg warum ist
selbst ein arabischer israeli er
verkörpert er ein held zwischen hoffnung
und kapitulation
so führt er auch wenn er an israel denkt
er hofft dass seine generation die
probleme dort lösen kann
wir sind jetzt in einer zeit wo die
jungen leute mehr fragen an sich selbst
stellen als früher das hängt stark mit
der aktuellen politischen situation
zusammen sie haben viele fragen und
kämpfen dafür dass sie auch antworten
bekommen hat gibt für die schule auf
ihre eltern verbieten ihr den
schulbesuch solange der araber in ihrer
klasse ist ihre beziehung zerbricht
denn die gräben zwischen der
israelischen und der palästinensischen
kultur erweisen sich als unüberwindbar
ein zarter versuch diesen konflikt zu
erfassen angesichts des krieges wirkt es
hier auf der piazza harmlos brutal
der blick in die russische gesellschaft
im film du lac ein spannender und einer
der stärksten filme in lugano in einem
zerfallenen mietshaus bricht eine
leitung auseinander
der klempner hat mit rieneck ihn stellt
fest nicht nur die leitung ist effekt
das ganze haus wird in kürze einstürzen
der überdimensionale riss im mauerwerk
ein starkes bild für eine völlig
zerrissene gesellschaft geht ins
nächtliche odyssee beginnt
er informiert die bürgermeisterin die
feiert gerade ihren fünfzigsten
geburtstag brüchige sozialbauten
interessieren sie da wenig
wird er muss sich jetzt
alle gegen alle bis auf einen der
klempner ist der einzige aufrichtige
mensch in dieser parabel 1 tura kein
idiot auf russisch als ich über den film
nachdachte orientierte ich mich an der
literatur den wurzeln der klassischen
russischen kultur und in dieser kultur
gibt es viele solche idioten figur der
idiot der durak ist immer allein und
lebt prinzipientreue als einziger die
bürgermeisterin entscheidet zu helfen
nur das budget der stadt ist
aufgebraucht
sie und ihre chefbeamten haben alles für
ein leben in saus und braus ausgegeben
für die evakuierung der randständigen
ist kein geld da der regisseur jurij
beecroft zeichnet ein düsteres
sittengemälde russlands ein land im
würgegriff von korruption und raffgier
es ist nicht nur ein problem der
russischen gesellschaft
es ist ein problem in jeder gesellschaft
wo es autoritäten gibt die macht über
andere haben und diese macht ausnutzen
details ausprägung mögen unterschiedlich
sein
die struktur ist immer gleich die
geschichte mag universell sein
dennoch liefert der spielfilm eine
trostlose zustandsbeschreibung russland
ohne solidarität und brutalisiert
durak stimmt nachdenklich und ist sicher
ein favorit für den goldenen leoparden